it's the first episode of new releases
of the year yes we're leaving behind
2014 and the year of remasters in
welcoming 2015 with a brand new week of
games and we're going to start with a
shoot well at least its resident evil
the infamous first game in a long
lasting serie there's loud players from
around the world with its horror film
inspired plot lines exploration and
puzzle-solving current gen console
owners will support 1080p resolution and
you can choose 16 by 9 or the original 4
by 3 aspect ratio either way you'll be
getting that same rush of fear each time
Jill turns a corner we live the horror
on the 20th but if you're looking for a
new story check out saints row because
johnny is going to hell in this new
standalone expansion gat out of hell
superhuman abilities return introducing
angelic flight which gives you wings
you'll be reuniting with deceased
enemies from stories passed in an effort
to save the Saints boss from marrying
Satan's daughter and more importantly
you'll get a locust gun that fires a
plague of frogs the expansion will also
be part of an upcoming re-release of
saints row 4 called saints row 4
reelected for ps4 and Xbox one you're
invited to the wedding from Hell on the
20th 3ds owners get an underrated
hardcore platformer with gunman Clive to
this week don't be fooled by the
simplistic artsy style this old-school
side scroller mixes up the pace
constantly and keeps you on your toes
with loads of various enemies and
intense boss fights certainly worth your
time if you've got that new 3ds start
shooting text on the twentieth
congratulations you've just been elected
as vice president of the world and with
that power comes responsibility you know
to recruit your family and friends to
fight all your shady battles for you
this RPG puts you in the chair of a
corrupt government official so go do
some research and delegate the dirty
work to save the world start wearing
three thousand dollar suits on the 20th
finally you're in the driver's seat of a
fast-paced spaceship with the next
Penelope as you traverse the galaxy
exploring the planets you gain new
abilities like transportation boosts
turret guns and bombs but all these
abilities cost energies you have to
balance your hot race moves with weapons
and defense to stay alive and finish
first you're in the hot seat January
22nd for further details visit gamespot
com release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week